can the Kardashians just retire
would be nice Kourtney Kardashian
responds to all the haters in her
comments That's so exciting the reality
star shared this clip to tick tock
reading some of the not so nice messages
people left on this video with her
longtime friend and business partner
Simon Huck you consider yourself a
wellness girly a wellness girly is a
giant or are you really short
fit Court especially keeps it real when
it comes to questions about her taste in
music fully owning that she may wear an
Agnostic Front band tee but doesn't
exactly fancy herself a fan absolutely
not and we're not playing that game
today it is a shirt from my husband's
closet and I will wear his shirts for
Life Court even addresses the fans who
threw shade at the production quality of
her video they could have hid the
microphone
that ring light is so bright LOL guys we
live for the ring light quartz fans
loved the clip which she simply
captioned tough love one follower
writing the sarcasm on Courtney's voice
is sending me another pleading Courtney
can you make this a series please
whatever happens happens yeah safe to
say Court isn't afraid to clap back at
the trolls online earlier this month
when someone left a comment on Instagram
asking if she's pregnant the mama three
responded citing her recent IVF Journey
as the reason for her changing
appearance I only acknowledge this
comment because I do think it's
important to know how IVF affects
women's bodies and it's not spoken about
much also are we still asking women if
they're pregnant
of course court and her husband Travis
Barker documented their attempts to
welcome a child during season one of the
family's Hulu reality show the
Kardashians Travis and I want to have a
baby and so my doctor took us down this
road of doing IVF and like it hasn't
been
the most amazing experience Court
admitted the process made a serious
impact on her mind and body the
medication basically like put me into
depression I just feel yeah a little bit
physically I might like myself super
moody and hormonal what has it been like
to be on the path to baby with Travis I
mean it's a beautiful thing that we'd
love to have happen
um but you know the journey is a bit
hard for any women who've been on it and
emotional
Court's already a mom to three kids with
her ex Scott Disick 13 year old mason
ten-year-old Penelope and eight-year-old
Reign while Travis has two kids with his
ex Shayna Moakler 19 year old Landon and
17 year old Alabama how tight are you
guys as a family my family means
everything to me so honestly as close as
it gets Court's a great mama and when it
comes to the haters we like to revisit
an iconic Courtney line ABCDEFG
I actually go what the heck is a b c d e
f g mean the conversation is over a b c
d e f g I have to go
cool
[Music]
okay